which Kevin has a superior meme a Kevin
Hart or B Kevin James I don't know they
went on a meme frenzy with me uh last
year so I'm going to go me I'm G to say
me wow really Kevin James Kevin are
funny though the the whole show cuz
they're very sitcom me all of Kevin
James memes were like very sitcom in the
show or face that you can attach but I
had a lot of stupid ones too I love that
it was close what's the best meme you've
seen of yourself there's one there's one
that they have with my hands where I'm
like I'm like this and they attach that
to a lot of stuff
like like when you when you don't have
enough money for the bill or when you're
out of excuses but your partner still
wants to argue like it's a lot I've seen
a lot of funny ones there